[Music]
stay where you are
you'll move who are these people we need
to get out of here are they with you not
an instrument shot
stop
sorry Helena Dr Jones it's over here
what do you want
[Music]
he's on the roof find another way up
Matthew Jones I'm not gonna hurt you
a good Moon
life rise at your feet
[Music]
water displacement get in the pool what
help me open the door well they didn't
get out the doors get in the pool okay
look at him
Archimedes
fascinating displacement
[Music]
boys
[Applause]
I'm retiring well in that case what are
we drinking same for the goddaughter God
told me you found something on a train
during the war a dial that could change
the course of history why are you
chasing the thing that drove your father
crazy
don't move please get out of here
sorry
Dr Jones get him
[Music]
Hitler made mistakes and with this I
will correct them all you stole it then
you stole it and then I stole it it's
called capitalism
thank you
[Applause]
passenger seat belt there might be some
tablets you've taken your chances made
your mistakes
and now a final Triumph
Indiana Jones a few times in my life
we're seeing things
I'm gonna torture with Voodoo
been shot nine times
included once by your father
ah sorry
[Music]
and I've been looking for this
all of my life
[Music]
we love Indiana Jones because we love
movies The Joy of those Adventures we
love the cause and effect the tripwire
of events all these pieces fit together
to make the lightning in a bottle of an
Indiana Jones film but also It just fits
Harrison like a glove
preparation was not really necessary
Harrison loves this character as much as
the audience loves this character so we
ask ourselves what could be the next
adventure and in this case it was what
could be the last adventure
we come to find him in 1969 the world
has changed around him he's retiring as
a professor and he's about to stumble
into an adventure sorry
it's filled with ore and excitement and
danger and they've completely captured
that
I felt good
and that we had made a film
that the audience deserved
I feel confident that we're gonna knock
their socks off
I've been looking for this all my life
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]